vous dites aussi un bon pour symboliser
l'année je vous le dis moi franchement
c'est une de mes plus belles années
franchement je dis la vérité j'ai passé
voilà avec vous je trouve qu'on a eu
tellement rigolé cette année ce soir je
pense que ça va être l'apothéose
benjamin bas justement on l'avait dit
pour moi le mot de cette année c'est
dark a remis à bosser tous les jours et
se marrer à chaque fois c'est un vrai
bonheur merci si c'est moi et on a des
aliments avait le mot de l'année
ça va prendre huit heures l'année
prochaine et ça va tomber ça fait du
tout le mot de l'année pour moi ces
frayeurs trayeur oui parce que j'ai vu
vous avez tout dit non parce que j'ai
été éloigné de vous correspondre un
petit mot enjoy
et je me suis rendu compte à quel point
la vie sans vous a été moins rigolote et
donc du personnage sa vie
professionnelle et amicale et vous
m'aviez fait terriblement manquer donc
j'ai une petite frayeur et je suis
heureuse arbre alors je vais donc noter
les mots pour voir si on peut faire une
phrase après total génère une histoire
et tous les maux qu'ils ont donnée donc
nadar cas et frayeur ensuite vont
triompher
ah oui on veut des audiences triomphe en
termes de contenu triomphe de l'adar cas
c'est un triomphe pour tpm et moi ça
sera léchage de boulot il dit
[Rires]
un bisou à voile et jean michel maire
moi c'était c'est inespéré
je savais la santé
il n'y a pas que cette année c'est
vraiment sûrs tous les ans il espérait
terminer l'année c'est pas qu'on sait
pas comment c'est vrai et je vous en
remercie
vous savez je pense voix et non inespéré
parce que suite aux petits polémique de
l'année dernière j'ai eu peur que leur
sort soit un peu distendues qui est un
peu puis un petit coup de mou et qu'on
n'arrive pas à reprendre la folie qu'on
avait mais heureusement vous aviez
gardez vous votre propre folie même si
nous on était un peu au départ un peu
frileux mais quand on dit les champs
fait les ce qui est bien ce qui va se
passer la lumière etc vous comme c'est
très flou il faisait assez de lumière
qui rendent pour éliminer la rochelle
excuse-moi de seconde mais la pointe ans
et un vent qui est distendu
eh ben je pensais pas qu'on a joué au
yoyo à la fin d'année comme sakho temps
de folie plus que l'année dernière
puisque les autres années chaque ça
s'est accéléré et c'est grâce à vous je
vous le dis vous nous avez pas lâcher
merci les chéris j'aurai plein de choses
à vous dire tout à l'heure vraiment et
je voudrais prépare un petit truc parce
que voilà je vous aime très fort oui
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur le mot qui
représente pour moi l'année tp mpc
chatoyant à 17 heures
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une émission qui exerce un attrait
sur les propos sur les images et je
trouve que c'est assez visuel donc choix
de jeu merci mais ça les prochaines vous
ferai pas le mot de la fin vous êtes
arrivé en fin d'année on oui ça fait
pile trois mois c'est vers la france ça
va sinon oui en plaire mais mon mot à
parce que je vois ça je me bats je pense
que vous avez quoi
alors mon mot c'est chrysalide comme les
années de crise et pour ce que tu peux
dire tu sais tu t'es sûr merci les
chrysalides c'est quoi j'ai fait une
fleur
c'est lorsqu'on subit en ce moment pas
pillages sur la mutation la métamorphose
de l'émission et en tant qu'ancien
membre du csa qui t'ai vu de ce que ça
d'ailleurs qu'il veut dire chrysalide
c'est ça oui ça aurait pu non mais je
pense en tant que joue avec les mots on
joue avec les veines
non mais faut dire que ça soit mignon
aujourd'hui de métamorphose a raison je
suis à l'ide vous c'est joey starr c'est
quoi une année glorieuse une année
glorieuse t'énerver quoi on est content
tout va bien on va faire que des dark à
un clip à l'ubs est une année de
conquête ou plutôt de reconquête une
année d'union sacrée j'ai adoré cette
année c'est ma meilleure ici alors
certes y avait plein de chroniqueurs
l'institut j'ai plein de nouveaux
chroniqueurs pas toujours talentueux
mais au moins son nom c'est en fait vous
à chaque fois mais sans déconner or ces
deux mecs là vous avez dit votre beau
oui avant goût et ben moi mon mot ses
murs du son à ce qu on a crevé mur du
son ouais c'est pas beau ça
alors qu on a crevé tous les plafonds
ont serré crozier oui on a crevé tous
les plafonds se réconcilie avec le csa
ouais on est bien mecha par marsu
castaner on a fêté les anniversaires
macro mathieu est revenu on s'est
réconcilié avec toutes les ligues
diverses et variées et donc ça peut pas
mieux touré m'a réconcilié que tf1 et ça
c'est votre ennemi c'est pas le mien ah
non non c'est bon aussi
si c'est mon ennemi sur le fait que ben
oui à bannac te ment solidarité mana
il n'aime pas c'est qu'ils vous aiment
pas ben voilà c'est je le regrette si
même pas écouté vous faites partie de la
bande qui détestent autorités oui mais
dans une famille on n'aime pas tous le
monde de la même manière vous
bon allez co2 alors votre bain mathieu
allée bacchus alors bon mot c'est alors
momo c'était renaissance j'ai dit ok
pourquoi pourquoi renaissance parce que
ça va qu'en début d'année c'est sûr
historique
non non non c'est que au début de
l'année c'est vrai quand l'émission
marché très mal et que quotidien était
devant devant de vente localement on
faisait quand même un million sont
mignons mais oui c'est à dire la vérité
les premiers mois je recevais des textos
de personnes qui me disait hanouna c'est
fini le roi a perdu sa couronne terminer
au pire à ce moment là j'étais assez
loin de vous qui vous en voyez ça on se
plaint de bertone personnes et puis
finalement finalement c'est vrai que
c'est la sellette alors que vous avez
vraiment et bien à force de devoir la
démission et tout ça est bien ses
revenus derrière et je reconnais que moi
le premier j'ai douté en septembre doute
à monter mais je dis vraiment je me suis
dit ah peut-être que voilà c'est fait
redouter en septembre octobre c'est le
moment où tu étais pas dans l'émission
voilà en fait je voulais pas revenir le
succès est revenu je suis revenu
mais pas sincèrement voir c'est vrai
c'est vrai que j'ai des textos de ça
vous madame
alors moi c'était une année éclectique
c'est un grand écart d'émotions et de
sensations et trèbes d'opinion et
c'était une sorte de cocktail et plus
cocktail explosif ça vous parle buffet à
volonté
oui je travaille au bistro romain voilà
donc réunir sur le même plateau
marlène schiappa ou afida turner est à
coup sûr tpm pixels et moi je trouve que
c'est extraordinaire c'est vrai que
cette année
sarrio on a eu du mal et le chat pas on
négocie bien afida turner
on est aussi bien christophe castaner on
a eu le président au téléphone mahidol
on a eu si c'est pas moi on est mieux
voilà paga on a réussit même à faire
cohabiter des personnes comme l'i
bien sûr bernard lagat de s'échanger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je dis des conneries
est ce que vous êtes heureuse est ce que
vous sentez bien comme ça c'est pourquoi
et ben ça m'arrange en plus parce qu'on
n'a pas le payer et ben brafman
elle faisait juste validé la toile n'a
pas levé des capitaux
alors à vous expérimental je dirai pas
ce que cette émission elle est tout à
fait incroyable c'est comme un happening
en art en arrondi ça c'est à dire que on
met des gens sur scène comme ça et il se
passe des choses souvent le plus souvent
imprévisible incroyable étonnante qui
amuse le public et c'est ça c'est
expérimental ça veut dire que c'est une
chose rare moi ça fait trente trois ans
de télévision qu'ici qu'on vit des
choses assez incroyables inattendu
amusante surprenant et vous étonner le
public tous les soirs parce qu'on ne
sait pas ce qui va arriver et nous non
plus et thé chaud là c'était bien le
manchot
[Applaudissements]
4/3 tout à l'heure je dirais intense
parce que en une année j'ai apprécié
avoir vécu sept ans comme des années de
chiens non mais vraiment parce que c'est
vrai qu'à un moment on a dit qu'on
travaillait pas où on a tous beaucoup
travaillé cette année et j'en ai pu m
illimité parce que vu le nombre de sms
qu'on a reçu cette année je penserai
provisions informalité marie t il pas
tous db c'est bien ils font leur boulot
mais met donc on est passé par toutes
les émotions et voilà c'est très très
riche cette année
carrie
[Applaudissements]